Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. It was still dark on the morning of Monday, November 15, 2004, when the alarm clock rang next to Peter Porco's bedside. The 52-year-old stirred, before leaning over to silence the alarm so it wouldn't wake his wife, Joan, who was sleeping beside him.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要帮助，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目说明。2004年11月15日，星期一的清晨，天色依然昏暗，彼得·波科床头的闹钟响了起来。52岁的彼得翻了个身，随后探过身去按掉闹钟，以免吵醒睡在身旁妻子琼。
The chill greeted Peter as he lifted himself out of bed, so he pulled on a sweater before heading down the hallway to the main bathroom. Peter stood at the vanity and looked at his reflection in the mirror. His eyes lowered to the sink in front of him, where he noticed several drops of blood. He collected a handful of tissues and attempted to clean the mess. The blood smeared across the porcelain, but didn't wipe away completely. Peter gave up and left the tissues in the sink. He then went downstairs to the kitchen to prepare for work.
寒意迎面扑来，彼得从床上坐起，他套上一件毛衣，然后沿着走廊走向主浴室。彼得站在梳妆台前，看着镜子中的自己。他的目光落在了眼前的洗手盆上，发现了几滴血迹。他抓起一把纸巾，试图清理这些污渍。血迹在瓷器上晕开，却没有完全擦掉。彼得放弃了，把纸巾留在了洗手盆里。接着，他下楼去厨房，为上班做准备。
Peter thumbed through some mail, unloaded the dishwasher, and took some food out of the fridge to make his lunch. As he went about his morning routine, Peter kept noticing drops of blood everywhere he went. Some he attempted to wipe up with tissues, others he left altogether. Peter then headed outside to collect the daily newspaper that had been delivered to his front porch. As he stepped out to grab it, the front door shut behind him and locked him out.
彼得翻了翻信件，清空了洗碗机，并从冰箱里拿了一些食物来做午餐。在进行晨间日常时，彼得不断发现自己走过的地方到处都有血迹。有些他试图用纸巾擦掉，有些则完全没有理会。随后，彼得出门去拿放在前廊的日报。当他走出去拿报纸时，前门在他身后关上并把他反锁在外。
This wasn't a problem, as there was a spare key underneath a flower pot by the door. As Peter retrieved the key and used it to re-enter the house, large droplets of blood dotted the porch steps. He left the key in the lock and let the door close behind him, though it remained slightly ajar. Peter took a few steps back towards the kitchen, but was unable to stand upright any longer. He collapsed forward, landing at the foot of the staircase. Peter and Joan Porco lived a simple and happy life in Delmar, a suburb approximately 150
这不是什么大问题，因为门边的一个花盆底下藏有一把备用钥匙。当彼得取回钥匙并用它重新进入房子时，门廊的台阶上点缀着大滴的血迹。他把钥匙留在锁里，任由大门在他身后关上，不过门还是微微敞开着。彼得向厨房方向退了几步，却再也无法站直身体。他向前倒下，摔倒在楼梯脚下。彼得和琼·波科在纽约市以北约150英里处的郊区德尔马过着简单而幸福的生活。
miles north of New York City. They took great pride in their cream and olive weatherboard home, which Joan kept spotless and organized. The Porcos treated their jobs with equal care and respect. Both were aged in their 50s and had worked in their respective fields for decades, Joan as a speech pathologist for a local elementary school, and Peter as a law clerk at the New York Supreme Court. Peter, who was known as Gentle Peter around the courthouse, had never missed a shift
他们对奶油色和橄榄绿色的木制外墙住宅感到非常自豪，琼把家里收拾得一尘不染、井井有条。波科夫妇对他们的工作也报以同等的关怀和尊重。两人都年过五十，在各自的领域工作了几十年，琼是当地一所小学的语言病理学家，彼得则是纽约最高法院的法律书记员。彼得在法院里被称为“温和的彼得”，他从未在没有通知同事的情况下
without informing his colleagues. So on November 15, 2004, when he failed to show up for work without explanation, concerns grew. Calls were placed to the Porcos' family home, but there was no answer. Peter's workmate, Michael, headed to the residence to make sure everything was alright. Michael drove down the quiet and leafy broccoli drive and pulled up in front of the Porcos' two-story house. From the street, everything appeared to be in order.
缺勤过。因此，在2004年11月15日这一天，当他无缘无故地没有去上班时，人们的担忧增加了。人们拨打了波科一家的住宅电话，但无人接听。彼得的同事迈克尔前往该住所，以确保一切安好。迈克尔开车驶入安静且绿树成荫的布罗科利大道，将车停在波科家那栋两层楼的房子前面。从街上看，一切似乎都很正常。
Michael pulled out his cell phone and dialed the Porcos' home number twice, but nothing stirred within the house. Michael then called his boss, who encouraged him to go up and knock on the front door. Michael kept his boss on the line as he headed up the driveway, and immediately realized something was amiss. The front door was slightly ajar and a key had been left in the lock. Worse still, a large smear of blood was visible on the doorknob, and several droplets were splattered around the porch.
迈克尔掏出手机，拨打了两次波科家的座机号码，但屋里毫无动静。迈克尔随即打电话给他的老板，老板鼓励他走过去敲前门。迈克尔一边沿着车道走，一边让老板保持通话，并立即意识到情况有些不对劲。前门微微敞开着，钥匙还插在锁上。更糟糕的是，门把手上明显有一大片血迹，门廊周围还溅落了数滴血。
Michael could hear the Porcos' pet golden retriever barking from somewhere inside. He asked his boss whether he should go in and was told to enter with caution. Michael carefully peered into the foyer before informing his boss. This is a crime scene, call an ambulance. At the base of the stairs, Peter Porco was lying motionless on the tiled floor, his eyes open and glazed. Blood from a severe head injury had soaked his clothes and was smeared all around him, including along the walls and on some interior doors.
迈克尔听到波科家的宠物金毛寻犬在屋里的某个地方吠叫。他问老板自己是否应该进去，老板告诉他要小心进入。迈克尔小心翼翼地窥视着门厅，然后告诉老板：“这是一个犯罪现场，快叫救护车。”在楼梯底部，彼得·波科面朝下倒在瓷砖地板上一动不动，双眼睁开且毫无光泽。严重头部受伤流出的血浸透了他的衣服，并涂抹在他周围的各处，包括墙壁和一些内门上。
Someone had walked through the blood, leaving red footprints throughout the crime scene. Paramedic Kevin Robert was driving his ambulance in a nearby street when he received a call notifying him of the situation unfolding on Broccoli Drive. He reached the Porco house and was summoned to the first floor by a detective who had arrived minutes earlier. Kevin carefully stepped around Peter Porco's lifeless body, ascended the stairs and entered the main bedroom. Inside, Joan Porco was lying horizontally across a blood-soaked bed.
有人曾踩着血走过，在整个犯罪现场留下了红色的脚印。急救人员凯文·罗伯特正驾驶着救护车在附近的一条街道上行驶，这时他接到一个电话，通知他布罗科利大道上正在发生紧急情况。他赶到波科家，被几分钟前到达的一名侦探叫上了二楼。凯文小心翼翼地绕过彼得·波科毫无生气的尸体，走上楼梯，进入了主卧室。在里面，琼·波科横躺在一张血迹斑斑的床铺上。
The walls above her were splattered in blood, as were the bedside tables. Joan's upper arms and hands had lacerations indicative of defensive wounds, but it was her head that had bore the brunt of the attack. One of her eyes was split in half and the side of her jaw was hanging from her face. Joan had been struck three times to her face and head while she was sleeping. The direction of the cast-off indicated only one assailant had carried out the violent assault. Lying at the foot of the bed was an axe covered in blood. The assailant had unleashed the same axe on Peter Porco a total of 16 times.
她头顶上方的墙壁上溅满了血迹，床头柜也是如此。琼的上臂和手部有表明是防御性伤口的撕裂伤，但遭受袭击最严重的部位是她的头部。她的一只眼睛裂成两半，侧脸的下巴挂在脸上。琼在睡觉时面部和头部遭到了三次重击。挥洒血迹的方向表明，只有一名凶手实施了这起暴力袭击。床脚躺着一把沾满血迹的斧头。凶手对彼得·波科挥舞了同一把斧头足足16次。
As this was 13 more hits than his wife, it appeared as though Peter was the intended victim. Judging by the amount of blood trailed throughout the house, it was initially thought that Peter had tried to run from his attacker, who chased him and hit him repeatedly until he collapsed. But the bloody footprints throughout the house only belonged to Peter. He wasn't being pursued by anyone. A medical examiner was able to shed light on the bizarre scenario that took place in
由于这比对他妻子的袭击多出13次，因此彼得似乎才是原本的目标。从全屋拖拽的血迹来看，最初人们认为彼得曾试图从袭击者手中逃跑，而凶手追赶他并反复击打他，直到他倒下。然而，房子里的血迹脚印只属于彼得。没有人尾随追赶他。法医得以揭开那天早上在屋里发生的诡异情景。
the house that morning. An autopsy showed that Peter had sustained severe damage to part of the brain responsible for higher-order functions such as perception, decision-making and language. However, the part of the brain that controls primal instinct and well-formed habits was undamaged. What actually happened was that like his wife, Peter was set upon while in bed. The killer had fled after carrying out the attack, unaware that Peter was still alive. Shortly after, Peter awoke to the sound of his alarm clock.
尸检显示，彼得的大脑中负责感知、决策和语言等高级功能的区域受到了严重损伤。然而，控制原始本能和熟练习惯的大脑区域却完好无损。实际情况是，彼得和他的妻子一样，是在床上遭到袭击的。凶手在行凶后逃离，并不知道彼得还活着。不久之后，彼得被闹钟的声音唤醒。
The part of his brain that would otherwise perceive his injured state was too damaged to function properly. So even when he stared at his caved-in skull in the bathroom mirror and began cleaning up his own dripping blood, Peter was unable to comprehend that he was critically hurt and needed urgent medical attention. However, his brain was still functioning in some capacity, allowing him to carry out his morning routine on instinct alone until he succumbed to blood loss. This was not the first time that Detective Chris Boudish had attended the Porco House.
他大脑中原本能感知自己受伤状态的部分受损严重，无法正常运作。因此，甚至当他在浴室镜子里凝视自己凹陷的头骨并开始清理自己滴落的鲜血时，彼得也无法理解自己受了重伤，需要紧急医疗救助。然而，他的大脑仍在某种程度上运转，使他仅凭本能完成了早上的日常起居，直到他因失血过多而倒下。这并不是侦探克里斯·鲍迪什第一次来到波科家。
Almost two years prior, he was called to the address following reports of a burglary. Peter and Joan had been awaiting the detective on their front porch. They were stressed, having just discovered that two laptops had been stolen from their house. The offender had seemingly gained access via the garage window by opening its frame and cutting through its mesh screen in a semi-circular manner. Lack of evidence prevented any arrests for the break-in, but it did prompt Peter and Joan to bolt the window shut and install a home security system.
将近两年前，他曾因接到入室盗窃的报告而被召至该地址。彼得和琼当时正在前廊等候侦探。他们感到压力很大，因为刚发现家里被偷了两台笔记本电脑。作案者似乎是通过车库窗户进入的，他撬开窗框，并以半圆形的方式割破了纱窗。由于缺乏证据，这起入室盗窃案未能逮捕任何人，但这确实促使彼得和琼把窗户用螺栓锁死，并安装了家庭安防系统。
In a town with a low crime rate, the burglary had stuck in Detective Boudish's mind and when Peter and Joan were found brutally attacked, he suspected a link between the two incidents. In both cases, the mesh screen of a window leading to the garage had been cut in a similar semi-circular manner. But during the murders, the intruder had also cut the home's phone line. They also smashed the LCD screen of the security system in the foyer. Only a single foreign fingerprint was found at the crime scene. It was uncovered on the door leading to the basement, where the couple's dog had been
在一个犯罪率很低的城镇里，这起入室盗窃案一直留在鲍迪什侦探的脑海里，当发现彼得和琼遭到残酷袭击时，他怀疑这两起事件之间存在联系。在这两起案件中，通往车库的窗户纱窗都以类似的半圆形方式被割破。但在谋杀案发生期间，入侵者还切断了家里的电话线。他们还砸碎了门厅安防系统的液晶屏幕。犯罪现场只发现了一个外国人的指纹。它是在通往地下室的门上被发现的，夫妻俩的狗就被关在那里。
locked away. Not even the murder weapon contained any foreign DNA or prints. It was clear the killer had been cautious not to leave behind any evidence that could result in them being identified. But to assume this was a burglary gone wrong didn't quite add up. Everything in the house was in its usual place and nothing had been rummaged or rifled through. Joan's purse, complete with credit cards, was lying untouched in the kitchen. Aside from the bloodstains, the house was in pristine condition.
甚至连凶器上也没有包含任何外国DNA或指纹。很明显，凶手非常谨慎，没有留下任何可能导致其身份暴露的证据。但如果认为这是一起入室盗窃未遂酿成的悲剧，那就有些说不通了。房子里的每样东西都在它们平常的位置上，没有任何东西被翻乱或搜查过。琼的钱包完好无损地放在厨房里，里面还有信用卡。除了血迹之外，房子保持着一尘不染的状态。
It appeared a far more sinister motive than robbery was at play this time. The intimacy of the crime, from the choice of murder weapon to the victim's wounds being centred around the head, indicated something more personal prompted the attack. Years earlier, Peter had been working as an appellate judge when he received a death threat from a man who was given an unfavourable ruling. Peter took the threat seriously and obtained a handgun for protection. He kept it by his bedside table, but as time passed and no action was taken against him, his worries dissipated.
这一次似乎存在着比抢劫更为阴险的动机。案件的私密性，从凶的选择到受害者伤口集中在头部，都表明促成此次袭击的是某种更加私人的原因。多年前，彼得曾担任上诉法官，当时他收到了一名因判决不利而心生不满的男子发出的死亡威胁。彼得对该威胁高度重视，并获得了一把手枪用于自卫。他把它放在床头柜旁，但随着时间流逝，对方并未采取进一步行动，他的担忧也随之消散。
Eventually, Peter stored the gun away in a closet. Following the murders, the man who had made the death threat was tracked down but cleared from the investigation after providing a solid alibi. Peter also had unlikely ties to the criminal underworld in that his great uncle, Frank Porco, was a known New York mobster. 30 years prior, Frank had arrived at Peter and Joan's wedding dripping in gold jewellery, flaunting large amounts of cash, and had a revolver strapped to his leg. There were rumours that Frank had snitched on his fellow mobsters, leading to the belief
最终，彼得把枪收进了衣柜里。谋杀案发生后，发出死亡威胁的那名男子被追踪到，但由于提供了不在场证明而洗脱了嫌疑。彼得与犯罪黑社会也有着不太可能的联系，他的曾叔父弗兰克·波科是纽约知名的黑手党成员。30年前，弗兰克曾穿着一身挂满黄金首饰、炫耀着大量现金的行头出现在彼得和琼的婚礼上，他的腿上还绑着一把左轮手枪。有传言称，弗兰克曾向其他黑手党同伙告密，这让人觉得
that Peter and Joan could have been targeted in retribution. This theory was bolstered by the fact that the perpetrator had used a fireman's axe, which was symbolic, given that Frank Porco was known within criminal circles as Frankie the Fireman. However, further examination of the axe revealed that it was not a fireman's axe as initially believed, but a regular one taken from the Porco's garage that they had purchased at a local hardware store. Additionally, Frank Porco had children, so it didn't make sense that anyone wishing
彼得和琼可能是遭到报复的目标。这一理论得到了以下事实的支持：凶手使用的是一把消防斧，鉴于弗兰克·波科在犯罪圈子里被称为“消防员弗兰基”，这具有象征意义。然而，对斧头的进一步检查显示，它并非最初认为的消防斧，而是从波科家车库拿走的一把普通斧头，是他们在当地五金店购买的。此外，弗兰克·波科有孩子，因此任何想要给他发送残酷信息的人反而把目标对准他的曾侄孙，这在逻辑上说不通。
to send him a cruel message would target his great nephew instead. Frank also had a history of refusing to cooperate with authorities, casting doubts that he was an informer. The theory that Frank Porco was in some way responsible for the attack on Peter and Joan just didn't add up. Then, a month after the axe attack, an envelope arrived at the headquarters of the Times Union newspaper in Albany, a city north of Delmar. As an employee handled it, a fine white powder poured out from one of the corners.
弗兰克也有拒绝与当局合作的历史，这让人怀疑他是否是一名告密者。弗兰克·波科在某种程度上应对彼得和琼遇袭负责的理论根本站不住脚。接着，在斧头袭击事件发生一个月后，一封信件送达了位于德尔马以北城市奥尔巴尼的《时代联盟报》总部。当一名员工经手这封信时，一包细微的白色粉末从其中一个角漏了出来。
They immediately notified the police. Inside was a letter from someone claiming responsibility for Peter Porco's death and stating that he was a starting point. It read, Peter was not even a challenge. Once I got inside, I repeatedly hit him in the head and neck with a small axe. I ignored all his pleading screams. If you ever want to find me, you might want to stop going after easy suspects.
他们立即通知了警方。里面是一封信，发信人声称对彼得·波科的死负责，并称这只是一个起点。信中写道：“彼得甚至算不上一个挑战。一旦我进屋，我就用小斧头反复击打他的头部和颈部。我无视了他所有的哀求尖叫。如果你想找到我，最好不要再去追查那些好对付的嫌疑人。”
Show me some respect I deserve. Catch me if you can. Tests revealed that the white powder was a non-harmful substance. Analysis of the letter failed to uncover any fingerprints or other characteristics that could help identify its author. A police lieutenant told the media he wouldn't classify the letter as a break in the case, rather just another avenue they were investigating. What the lieutenant didn't disclose was that police had quickly ruled the letter out as
“请给予我应有的尊重。有本事就来抓我。”测试显示，白色粉末是一种无害物质。对这封信的分析未能发现任何指纹或其他有助于确定作者身份的特征。一名警务中尉对媒体表示，他不会将这封信归类为案件的突破口，而只是他们正在调查的另一条途径。这位中尉没有透露的是，警方很快就将这门信件排除在恶作剧之外。
a hoax. They were already zeroing in on who they strongly suspected was responsible for the murders. A person who had been identified by Joan Porco herself. Detective Chris Boudish had been the first officer to arrive to the Porco's house following the discovery of the crime scene. He immediately carried out a rudimentary sweep of the downstairs rooms. While he didn't come across any intruders, he found the Porco's pet dog locked in the basement.
他们已经将目标锁定在他们强烈怀疑对谋杀案负责的人身上。一个被琼·波科本人认出的人。克里斯·鲍迪什侦探是发现犯罪现场后第一位抵达波科家警官。他立即对楼下的房间进行了初步搜查。虽然他没有遇到任何入侵者，但他发现波科家的宠物狗被锁在地下室里。
Boudish then headed up to the first floor to canvas the rooms there. He arrived at the main bedroom to find the badly beaten body of Joan Porco. Shockingly, Joan's hand weakly raised into the air. Not only was she still alive, but she was still conscious. She motioned for Boudish to enter. He asked if she could hear him. Although Joan was unable to speak due to her injuries, she was able to communicate by nodding and shaking her head.
随后，鲍迪什前往一楼搜查那里的房间。他来到主卧室，发现了遭受严重殴打的琼·波科的身体。令人震惊的是，琼的手无力地举在空中。她不仅还活着，而且还保持着清醒。她示意鲍迪什进去。他问她能否听到他说话。尽管琼因伤无法说话，但她能够通过点头和摇头来交流。
Fearing Joan would pass away before paramedics arrived, Detective Boudish began asking her questions in a desperate bid to gather key evidence. He asked if a family member had done this to her. Joan nodded. He asked if it was Jonathan. Joan motioned with her hand. No. Detective Boudish then asked if her other younger son, Christopher, was responsible.
由于担心琼会在急救人员到达之前离世，鲍迪什侦探开始向她提问，拼命想要收集关键证据。他问是不是某个家庭成员对她做出了这种事。琼点了点头。他问是不是乔纳森。琼用手示意：不是。鲍迪什侦探随后问她的另一个小儿子克里斯是否应该负责。
Joan nodded. Boudish repeated the question. Again, Joan signalled yes. At 2.45 that afternoon, a reporter for the Times Union newspaper placed a call to the University of Rochester in West New York State. 21-year-old Christopher Porco was enrolled to study biomedical engineering and economics there. When he answered the call, the reporter asked Chris if he had any comment to give in relation
琼点了点头。鲍迪什重复了这个问题。琼再次示意是。那天下午2点45分，《时代联盟报》的一名记者向纽约州西部的罗切斯特大学拨打了电话。21岁的克里斯·波科当时在那里注册学习生物医学工程和经济学。当他接听电话时，记者问克里斯对于他的父母被杀一事是否有任何评论。
to his parents being killed. It was the first Chris had been informed of the attack. He asked the reporter what she was talking about. She said she couldn't tell him anything and would call him back. Chris dropped the phone in shock. He sat around in his dorm room waiting to hear back, but the phone didn't ring. After composing himself, he phoned 911 for an explanation. While the operator tried to ascertain what had happened, Chris received a text from his
这是克里斯第一次得知袭击事件。他问记者在说些什么。她说她什么也不能告诉他，并会回电话。克里斯震惊得手机都掉了下来。他坐在宿舍里等着回电，但电话没有响。平复心情后，他拨打911寻求解释。正当接线员试图弄清楚发生了什么时，克里斯收到了女友发来的一条短信。
girlfriend. News had spread that his parents' house had been cordoned off with police tape and officials were swarming the area. Chris was completely unaware that police had issued an alert to be on the lookout for him, with the report urging officers to use caution as Chris might be armed. An uncle picked Chris up from campus and drove him to Delmar. The near four hour journey was a solemn one. Chris, dazed and visibly shaken, stared out the passenger window, barely speaking a word.
有消息传开，他父母的房子已被警察的警戒线拉起，官员们正蜂拥而至该地区。克里斯完全不知道警方已经发布了搜寻他的警报，报告敦促警官们保持谨慎，因为克里斯可能持有武器。一位叔叔从校园接起克里斯，开车送他去德尔马。近四个小时的车程沉重而肃穆。克里斯神情恍惚、明显受到惊吓，呆呆地望着副驾驶的车窗，几乎一言不发。
Paramedics fought hard to save Joan Porco, but had trouble placing an oxygen mask over her mouth and nose as they couldn't make out her facial features. Her blood pressure was almost non-existent and brain matter was visible through the wounds in her skull. She was rushed to hospital to undergo emergency surgery, but the situation was dire. Chris Porco arrived at the hospital while his mother was undergoing treatment. He was immediately swarmed and hugged by friends and relatives who had gathered in the waiting room awaiting news of Joan's state.
急救人员全力抢救琼·波科，但在将氧气面罩戴到她的口鼻上时遇到了困难，因为他们无法辨认出她的面部特征。她的血压几乎为零，透过头骨上的伤口甚至可以看到脑组织。她被紧急送往医院接受急诊手术，但情况十分危急。克里斯·波科在母亲接受治疗期间赶到了医院。他立刻被聚集在候诊室里等待琼状况消息的朋友和亲戚们包围并拥抱。
At one stage, a family friend broke the news to Chris that he was a suspect in the attack. Shocked, Chris asked how anyone could think he would hurt his parents. Peter and Joan Porco were a loving couple who made sure that their children never went without. By 2004, the Porcos were empty nesters, though remained close to both their sons, Jonathan and Christopher. Christopher had inherited his father's looks and magnetic sociable personality. Described as a popular and charming person who was always smiling, Chris was also intelligent,
有那么一瞬间，一个家庭朋友向克里斯透露了一个消息：他是袭击案的嫌疑人。克里斯大受震惊，质问怎么会有人认为他会伤害自己的父母。彼得和琼·波科是一对充满爱心的夫妻，他们确保自己的孩子衣食无忧。到2004年，波科夫妇已经成了空巢老人，不过他们与两个儿子乔纳森和克里斯的关系依然紧密。克里斯继承了父亲的长相和富有磁性的社交个性。被描述为受欢迎且迷人、总是面带微笑的人，克里斯也很聪明，
scoring in the top 95% nationally following his high school graduation. A member of the local church youth group, his university swim team and a former vet technician, Chris was a hard worker with many interests. To friends, Chris had no discernible reason to murder his parents. He spoke positively of his affluent childhood and took his friends on driving tours of his old neighborhood to point out the mansion he'd grown up in. In fact, Chris was so well off that he'd let it slip that he had $2.8 million in a trust account held in the Cayman Islands.
高中毕业后全国排名前95%。作为当地教会青年团契的成员、大学游泳队的队员以及前兽医技术员，克里斯是一个有很多兴趣的勤奋工作者。在朋友看来，克里斯没有任何明显的理由去谋杀他的父母。他积极地谈论自己富裕的童年，并带朋友们开车游览他以前的街区，指出他长大的豪宅。事实上，克里斯非常有钱，以至于他不小心说漏嘴，自己在开曼群岛的一个信托账户里有280万美元。
He'd also purchased an impressive home in North Carolina. He happily shared his wealth, sharing his friends with gifts and shouting them drinks from a stockpile of cash he always kept on him. However, it hadn't always been smooth sailing for Chris Porco. In 2002, a prolonged bout of glandular fever caused him a temporary setback, but with the unwavering support and help of his parents, he was able to recover and return to his studies. Joan would make the seven-hour round trip to Rochester whenever she could to look after Chris during his recovery.
他还买下了北卡罗来纳州一套令人印象深刻的房子。他很高兴地分享自己的财富，用礼物对待朋友，并用他随身携带的大量现金请他们喝酒。然而，克里斯·波科的生活并非总是一帆风顺。2002年，一场长时间的腺热让他遭受了暂时的挫折，但在父母坚定不移的支持和帮助下，他得以康复并重返学业。每当有机会照顾处于康复中的克里斯时，琼都会进行往返罗切斯特、长达七小时的车程。
It was clear to all those who knew Peter and Joan Porco that they loved their children. When Chris saw the swollen and maimed state his mother was in following the axe attack, he burst into tears and fell to the floor. As Joan was taken into surgery, Chris was met by a detective and agreed to go to the police station for questioning. Throughout the interrogation, Chris was polite and cooperative. Although he returned to Del Mar periodically to visit his parents, he hadn't stayed with them for three weeks.
所有认识彼得和琼·波科的人都清楚，他们深爱着自己的孩子。当克里斯看到遭受斧头袭击后母亲肿胀残缺的模样时，他放声大哭并瘫倒在地上。当琼被推入手术室时，克里斯遇到了一名侦探，并同意前往警察局接受盘问。在整个审讯过程中，克里斯表现得很有礼貌且十分配合。尽管他定期回到德尔马探望父母，但他已经有三个星期没有和他们住在一起了。
He denied involvement in the brutal attack and provided an alibi for the night in question. At 9.30pm, Chris went out to dinner with a friend in Rochester before returning to the on-campus dormitory where he lived. He exchanged online messages with his girlfriend, then settled into the dorm's common room to watch a movie. It went on into the early hours, during which Chris fell asleep on the sofa. He was still sleeping there when another student entered at 10am the following morning. Chris had nothing to hide.
他否认参与了这起残酷的袭击，并为案发当晚提供了不在场证明。晚上9点30分，克里斯和罗切斯特的一位朋友出去吃晚饭，然后返回他居住的校内宿舍。他与女友进行了网上聊天，随后在宿舍的公共休息室安顿下来看电影。电影一直放到清晨，期间克里斯在沙发上睡着了。第二天早上10点另一名学生进来时，他依然睡在那里。克里斯没有什么可隐瞒的。
He let police take his fingerprints and blood for testing. When asked to lift his shirt so they could check for superficial injuries that might indicate his involvement in the attack, Chris was happy to do so. He also supplied the clothing he was wearing so it could undergo analysis. His car was also seized. Yet, neither his vehicle nor his clothes contained blood or hair from either one of his parents, as would be expected from such a violent crime. Despite his cooperation, Chris sensed the police were convinced he was guilty.
他让警方采集了他的指纹和血液用于检测。当被要求撩起衬衫以便警方检查可能表明他参与袭击的表皮伤痕时，克里斯也很乐意照做。他还提供了他当时穿的衣服以便进行分析。他的车也被扣押了。然而，无论是他的车还是他的衣服，都没有包含其父母任何一方的血液或头发，而这本该是这样一起暴力犯罪所应有的。尽管他很配合，但克里斯感觉到警察确信他是有罪的。
Peter and Jones' eldest son, 23-year-old Jonathan, was away on assignment with the US Navy at the time, so as far as police were concerned, there weren't any other viable suspects. For Chris, his interrogators seemed to be getting angrier and angrier as the hours passed. They accused him over and over, to the point that he became afraid of them. He continued to help investigators, but was rattled by their unwavering suspicion. He agreed to participate in a polygraph test, but refused to do so without an attorney present. This request, along with his right to legal counsel during his interrogation, was denied.
彼得和琼的大儿子、23岁的乔纳森当时正在随美国海军执行任务，因此在警方看来，没有其他可行的嫌疑人了。对克里斯来说，审讯他的人随着时间的推移似乎变得越来越愤怒。他们一次又一次地指责他，以至于他开始害怕他们。他继续协助调查人员，但被他们坚定不移的怀疑弄得心神不宁。他同意参加测谎仪测试，但拒绝在没有律师在场的情况下进行。这一请求以及他在审讯期间获得法律辩护的权利遭到了拒绝。
Chris wasn't even read his full Miranda rights. Instead, he was forced to sign a copy that he didn't have time to read. After six hours, Chris was finally permitted to leave the police station. He returned to the hospital to check on his mother. Against all odds, Joan Porco survived her 12-hour surgery and was placed into a medically induced coma, though doctors didn't expect her to recover. A priest read Joan her last rights in anticipation of her death. Three weeks later, Joan Porco miraculously awoke.
甚至连他的米兰达警告权利都没有完全向克里斯宣读。相反，他被迫在一份自己没有时间阅读的复印件上签字。六个小时后，克里斯终于获准离开警察局。他回到医院查看母亲的情况。克服重重困难，琼·波科挺过了长达12小时的手术，并被置于药物诱导的昏迷状态，尽管医生并不期望她能康复。为了迎接她可能离世的结局，一位神父向琼作了临终祈祷。三个星期后，琼·波科奇迹般地醒了过来。
She had lost her left eye, part of her skull had been removed, and her face was permanently scarred. Damage to her throat left her with a quiet, whispering voice, but she had survived. The problem was, Joan had no memory of the attack. She remembered what she'd done in the days leading up, such as visiting the YMCA, working in the yard, and going to church, but recalled nothing of November 15. Most crucially, she couldn't recall identifying her youngest son as her attacker and denied ever doing so.
她失去左眼，部分头骨被切除，面部永久留疤。喉部的损伤让她只能用低声耳语说话，但她活了下来。问题是，琼对这起袭击毫无记忆。她记得案发前几天做过的事，比如去基督教青年会、在院子里干活、去教堂，但对11月15日的事毫无记忆。最关键的是，她不记得自己曾指认小儿子是袭击者，并且否认曾说过这话。
She knew in her heart that Chris was innocent. Joan did remember a strange incident that occurred two weeks prior. One night, the motion sensor lights outside the Porco's home went off. Joan went to investigate and noticed a shadowy figure loitering in the driveway. The police, including Detective Boudish, were informed of the incident, but didn't investigate the matter. Joan's instincts told her that there was more to this encounter than the police believed, yet they continued to try and convince her of Chris's guilt.
她内心深处知道克里斯是无辜的。琼确实记得两周前发生的一起奇怪事件。一天晚上，波科家外面的运动传感器灯亮了。琼前去查看，发现一个黑影在车道上徘徊。包括鲍迪什侦探在内的警方被告知了这起事件，但并没有对此进行调查。琼的直觉告诉她，这次遭遇并不像警方认为的那样简单，然而他们却继续试图让她相信克里斯有罪。
Joan remained steadfast. Chris was not responsible. She wrote a letter to the editor of The Times Union newspaper, which read, Thanks to wonderful doctors, numerous medical treatments, and surgeries, I have survived. I continue to improve, and even though I have suffered a grievous injury, both physical and emotional, I thank God for my life. Unfortunately, the horror and unbearable sadness I continue to feel as a result of the loss of Peter has been dramatically intensified by the trauma that our cherished son, Chris,
琼依然立场坚定。克里斯没有责任。她给《时代联盟报》的编辑写了一封信，信中写道：“多亏了优秀的医生、众多的医疗护理和手术，我活了下来。我的情况在不断改善，尽管我遭受了身体和情感上的双重严重创伤，但我感谢上帝赐予我生命。不幸的是，由于失去彼得，我继续感受到的恐惧和难以忍受的悲伤，由于我们深爱的儿子克里斯被迫忍受的创伤而急剧加剧，”
has been forced to endure. I want to say unequivocally that, although I have no memory whatsoever of the attack, either because I was asleep or because of my injuries, I am absolutely positive that my son was in no way involved in this heinous crime. He is an intelligent, compassionate, peaceful and loving person, and no one could ask for a better son. He, Peter, our older son Jonathan, and I, have always had a wonderful relationship, and Chris would never hurt any one of us.
“我想明确地指出，尽管我对袭击事件没有任何记忆，无论是因为我在睡觉还是因为我的伤势，但我绝对确信我的儿子绝对没有参与这起滔天罪行。他是一个聪明、富有同情心、爱好和平且充满爱心的人，没有人能要求更好的儿子了。他、彼得、我们的大儿子乔纳森以及我，一直都保持着极好的关系，克里斯绝不会伤害我们中的任何人。”
I implore the police and the district attorney's office to leave my son alone, and to search for Peter's real killer or killers, so that he can rest in peace, and my sons and I can live in safety. Hi. My name is Chris Borgo. I was just called by the time the union was saying that my parents were found dead. I was wondering if you had any information. I'm at school in Rochester, New York.
“我恳求警方和地方检察官办公室放过我的儿子，去寻找彼得真正的凶手或凶手们，以便他能够安息，而我的儿子们和我能够生活在安全之中。嗨。我叫克里斯·波尔戈。我刚接到《时代联盟报》的电话，说我的父母被发现死了。我想知道你是否有任何信息。我在纽约州罗切斯特的上学。”
Okay. Okay. Do you have a phone number there, Chris? Yeah. Sure do. Okay. Are you in? No.
“好的。好的。你在那里有一个电话号码吗，克里斯？”“对。当然有。”“好的。你在……吗？”“不。”
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
“不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。”
“不。不。不。不。不. 不。不。不。”
No. No. No. No. No. No. No. No.
“不。不。不。不。不。不。不。不。”
No. No. No. No. No, I don't understand Lee. parents are dead. She had been messaging Chris on and off throughout the day, aware that a situation was unraveling at his parents' place in Delmar.
“不。不。不。不。不，我不明白，李。父母死了。”她一整天断断续续地给克里斯发信息，意识到他父母在德尔马的住所正发生着变故。
He had messaged her earlier, telling her that he wasn't feeling well, and that, quote, he hadn't heard from his parents all morning, and that he was nervous. Chris didn't message his girlfriend again after revealing that his parents were deceased. His uncle John picked him up from campus and drove him straight to Delmar. As they neared their destination, John received a call from a family friend. He had something important to say, but it was imperative that he keep it from Chris. Chris was a suspect in his parents' attack. Chris cooperated with investigators, saying that he wanted to be as helpful as he could
他早些时候曾给她发信息，说他感觉身体不舒服，并且“引述：他整个早上都没有收到父母的消息，这让他感到紧张。”在透露父母已经去世后，克里斯没有再给女友发过信息。他的叔叔约翰从校园接起他，直接开车送他去德尔马。随着他们接近目的地，约翰接到了一位家庭朋友的电话。他有重要的话要说，但必须对克里斯严格保密。克里斯是父母遇袭案的嫌疑人。克里斯配合了调查人员，表示他希望尽可能地提供帮助，
so they could find the killer as quickly as possible. When asked if he committed the brutal assault, Chris replied, You know, I can't say enough, absolutely no. I would never do anything like that to anyone, let alone my parents, who I love dearly. Following Joan Porco's life-saving surgery, Chris stood vigil by her side. A youth minister comforted him and was struck by Chris's odd behavior. He didn't sense any grief from the young man. Just over 200 miles west, detectives were following up Chris's alibi at his dormitory
以便他们能以最快的速度找到凶手。当被问及是否犯下了这起残酷的袭击时，克里斯回答说：“你知道，我怎么说都不为过，绝对没有。我绝不会对任何人做那样的事，更不用说我深爱的父母了。”在琼·波科接受了拯救生命的的手术后，克里斯守候在她身旁。一位青年牧师安慰了他，并对克里斯怪异的行为感到震惊。他在这个年轻人身上感觉不到任何悲伤。在正西200多英里外，侦探们正在罗切斯特的宿舍里核实克里斯的不在场证明。
in Rochester. Chris maintained he was asleep on the common room sofa on the night of the attack. While another student recalled seeing him asleep on the sofa at 10am, no one could vouch for him being there overnight. Several other students claimed they had been in the common room until 3.30am and at no time was Chris present. It was only a small square room with a few couches and a television, so he would be impossible to miss.
克里斯坚称自己在袭击当晚睡在公共休息室的沙发上。虽然另一位学生回忆说曾在上午10点看到他在沙发上睡觉，但没有人能证明他整晚都在那里。其他几名学生声称他们在凌晨3点半之前一直待在公共休息室里，而克里斯在任何时候都不在场。那只是一个只有几张沙发和一台电视的小正方形房间，因此他是不可能被忽视的。
One student assured, It's not like maybe he was there and we overlooked him. He wasn't there. It was approaching 11am on the night of November 14, 2004, marking the end of a long shift for toll collector John Fallon. John stood alone in a booth at the exit 46 tolls in the suburb of Henrietta, just off the New York State Thruway. Craving a cigarette, John discreetly lit one up while keeping an eye out in case his boss suddenly approached.
一名学生确信地说：“不像他可能在那儿而我们漏掉了他。他当时不在。”2004年11月14日晚接近11点，标志着收费员约翰·法伦漫长值班的结束。约翰独自站在位于纽约州高速公路旁的亨利埃塔郊区46号出口收费站的一个岗亭里。烟瘾犯了的约翰一边偷偷点上一根烟，一边留意着老板是否会突然走过来。
At 10.46pm, a bright yellow Jeep Wrangler caught John's attention. He'd been on the lookout for a new car for his son and had always loved Jeets. This one was a particularly nice model and John noted its wide tyres and black canvas top. It drove through John's toll lane and pulled up to the booth where he was waiting. The driver was a white man aged in his 20s wearing a baseball cap. He was travelling alone. Although cashless tolling was available to vehicles that had an electronic easy pass
晚上10点46分钟，一辆亮黄色的吉普牧马人引起了约翰的注意。他一直在为儿子物色新车，并且一直很喜欢吉普车。这一辆是一款特别漂亮的车型，约翰注意到了它的宽轮胎和黑色帆布车顶。它驶过约翰的收费车道，停在他等候的岗亭旁。司机是一名20多岁的白人男子，戴着棒球帽。他独自一人出行。尽管安装了电子不停车收费
tag installed, this driver didn't appear to have one. Instead, he opted to pay for the toll with cash. John handed him a ticket, which gave the Jeep access to the New York State Thruway, a system of controlled access highways spanning over 550 miles across the state. He then let the Jeep continue onwards before stubbing out his cigarette and finishing his shift. Just over three hours later, toll collector Karen Russell was preparing to go on her break. Her booth was located 230 miles west of Henrietta at exit 24 of Interstate 87 just outside the
标签的车辆可以使用无现金收费，但这位司机似乎并没有安装。相反，他选择用现金支付通行费。约翰递给他一张票，这张票允许吉普车进入纽约州高速公路，这是一个贯穿该州550多英里的受控通道高速公路系统。然后，他让吉普车继续前行，随后掐灭香烟，结束了他的班次。仅仅三个多小时后，收费员凯伦·拉塞尔正准备去休息。她的岗亭位于亨利埃塔以西230英里的87号州际公路24号出口，就在德尔马郊区外。
suburb of Delmar. Karen was working the 10pm to 6am shift when at 1.51am she noticed a car speeding down her lane. It came to an abrupt stop at her booth. Karen eyed the driver that was a young man with brown hair. She collected a toll ticket from him and sent him on his way. He hit the accelerator and sped off into the darkness. Although Karen ticketed 24 more vehicles before she finally went on her break, she never forgot
凯伦上的是晚上10点到早上6点的班，当时在凌晨1点51分，她注意到一辆车正超速驶入她的车道。它在她的岗亭前猛地停了下来。凯伦打量着司机，那是一个留着棕色头发的年轻人。她收下了他的通行费票，并放他上路。他踩下油门，加速驶入黑暗中。尽管凯伦在最终去休息之前又给24辆车发了票，但她永远没有忘记
this one. Given that the car was travelling so fast and dangerously, Karen remembered the yellow Jeep Wrangler vividly. Rockley Drive in Delmar was predictably dark and quiet at 4am on November 15, 2004 when local resident Marshall got in his car to head off for work. For a moment, his headlights swept over his neighbour's property. They illuminated a yellow Jeep Wrangler parked in the driveway. Marshall had seen the vehicle before speeding up and down the street with music glaring.
这一辆。鉴于这辆车开得如此之快且充满危险，凯伦对那辆黄色的吉普牧马人记忆犹新。2004年11月15日凌晨4点，德尔马的罗克利大道一如既往地黑暗而安静，当地居民马歇尔上车准备去上班。一瞬间，他的车头灯扫过了邻居的物业。它们照亮了停在车道上的一辆黄色吉普牧马人。马歇尔以前曾见过这辆车在街上伴随着震耳欲聋的音乐超速行驶。
Although it had caught Marshall's attention as it sat stationary in front of the home belonging to Peter and Joan Porco, it wasn't an unusual sighting. He knew who owned the car. As such, he thought nothing of it and continued onwards. The sighting of the yellow Jeep in the Porco's driveway at the time of the attack was a crucial one for detectives. They were able to trace its movements through the toll booths which had been captured on CCTV footage.
尽管当它静止不动地停在属于彼得和琼·波科的住宅前时引起了马歇尔的注意，但这并不是一个不寻常的景象。他知道谁拥有这辆车。因此，他没把这当回事，继续往前开了。袭击发生时，在波科家车道上看到黄色吉普车，对侦探来说至关重要。他们能够通过已被闭路电视监控录像捕捉到的收费站来追踪它的行踪。
While the footage wasn't clear enough for the Jeep's number plates to be visible, a video analyst was able to enhance the footage enough to notice some clues. On the passenger side door, a torn barcode sticker on the passenger side window, and an oval sticker on the spare tyre cover. There was little doubt at this stage who the car belonged to, but these small details confirmed it. The day after his parents were attacked, Chris Porco's yellow Jeep Wrangler was seized for forensic examination.
虽然录像不够清晰，无法看清吉普车的车牌，但视频分析师能够将录像进行增强，从而注意到一些线索。在副驾驶一侧的车门上，副驾驶车窗上有一个撕裂的条形码贴纸，备胎罩上还有一个椭圆形贴纸。在这个阶段，这辆车属于谁几乎毫无疑问，但这些小细节证实了这一点。父母遇袭的第二天，克里斯·波科的黄色吉普牧马人就被扣押进行法医检查。
Photographs of the Jeep were compared to the vehicle caught traveling from Henrietta to Delmar the night of the attack. They were a match. Marshall, who had sighted the Jeep in the Porco's driveway, also identified it as Chris Porco's car. Henrietta was a suburb of the city of Rochester where Chris studied. In a fortunate break for detectives, new security cameras had been installed throughout the exterior of the campus, including the car parks.
吉普车的照片与袭击当晚拍到从亨利埃塔开往德尔马的车辆进行了比对。它们吻合了。在波科家车道上看到过这辆吉普车的马歇尔也将其辨认为克里斯·波科的车。亨利埃塔是克里斯求学的罗切斯特市的一个郊区。在侦探们运气不错的一个突破中，整个校园外部都安装了新的安全摄像头，包括停车场。
They examined 880 hours of footage during which Chris's yellow Jeep Wrangler was filmed leaving the campus at 10.30pm on November 14, hours before the attack. This timing aligned with the 15 minutes it took the vehicle to travel to the Exit 46 toll booth where the Jeep was captured on camera and witnessed by toll collector John Fallon. It then drove near 3 hours east towards Delmar before Karen Russell at Exit 24 centred onwards from her toll booth. At 8.30am, Chris's Jeep was filmed pulling in to the University of Rochester car park. Shortly thereafter, Chris was sighted by another student wearing a baseball cap and slowly
他们检查了880小时的录像，期间克里斯的黄色吉普牧马人在11月14日晚上10点30分被拍到离开校园，即袭击发生数小时前。这个时间与这辆车行驶15分钟到达46号出口收费站的时间相吻合，在收费站这辆吉普车被摄像头拍到并被收费员约翰·法伦目击。随后它向东行驶了近3个小时来到德尔马，之后凯伦·拉塞尔在24号出口放行了它驶离收费站。早上8点30分，克里斯的吉普车被拍到驶入罗切斯特大学的停车场。此后不久，克里斯被另一名学生目击，他戴着棒球帽，正慢跑着朝宿舍方向跑去。
jogging towards his dormitory. At 10am, a fellow resident saw him sleeping on the common room so far. An electronic easy pass tag was found on the floor of Chris's Jeep. This would have enabled him to drive through the toll booths without having to stop and pay cash. It was suspected he had removed it from its usual position on the windshield and opted for the manual ticketed toll system to avoid being digitally tracked. In another lucky break for investigators, the toll tickets collected on the night of
上午10点，另一位同住宿舍的学生看到他睡在公共休息室的沙发上。在克里斯的吉普车地板上发现了一个电子不停车收费标签。这将使他能够无需停车支付现金就能穿过收费站。据怀疑，他将其从挡风玻璃上通常的位置取下，并选择了人工领卡收费系统，以避免被数字化追踪。在调查人员的又一次幸运突破中，案发当晚收集到的通行费票
the attack hadn't yet been destroyed. John contained mitochondrial DNA that undisputedly linked it to Chris. While the Porco's home security system had been smashed, its records revealed it had first been disarmed using the master code. Chris was one of only six people who knew the code. Police suspected that he smashed the system's screen to fool them into thinking that the intruder had disarmed the device this way. They also suspected he had worn a pair of scrubs obtained from his time working in the veterinary
袭击尚未被破坏。John身上含有无疑与Chris有关的线索的线粒体DNA。虽然波科家的家庭安防系统被砸坏了，但记录显示，该系统最初是用主密码解除布防的。Chris是知道这个密码的仅有的六个人之一。警方怀疑他砸碎系统屏幕，是为了误导他们，让他们以为入侵者是用这种方式解除设备布防的。他们还怀疑他穿着一套在他曾经工作过的兽医
clinic to avoid soiling his clothes with his parents' blood. His extensive work in cleaning up after veterinary procedures would have given him ample skills to clean up a bloody crime scene and any staining in his car. In a final blow to Chris's professions of innocence, the fingerprint on the basement door was matched to his own. Despite Joan Porco refuting that she had implicated her son in the immediate aftermath of her attack, Detective Boudish remained firm that Chris Porco was responsible. He recalled the time he visited the Porco residence years prior to investigate the matter
诊所里拿的手术服，以免父母的血弄脏自己的衣服。他在处理兽医手术后的善后工作中积累了丰富的经验，这让他有足够的技能来清理血腥的犯罪现场以及车内的任何血迹。给Chris自称无罪的辩白以致命一击的是，地下室门上的指纹与他本人的吻合。尽管琼·波科否认自己在遭受袭击后不久曾暗示儿子是凶手，但布迪什侦探仍然坚信克里斯·波科难辞其咎。他回想起自己多年前造访波科住宅调查此事的情形：
of the two stolen laptops. Although the house had all the hallmarks of a burglary, Boudish was certain the crime scene was staged. His suspicions only increased after the axe attack. Similar to the laptop robbery, a mesh window screen had been slashed in the garage, indicating the intruder's entry point. However, the garage window had since been bolted shut and was also covered in cobwebs. It was clear no one had come through there and that the mesh had been cut from the inside.
那两台被盗的笔记本电脑。尽管这所房子具备了入室盗窃的一切特征，但布迪什确信犯罪现场是伪造的。斧头袭击事件发生后，他的怀疑有增无减。与笔记本电脑盗窃案相似，车库的一扇窗纱被割破了，这表明了入侵者的入口。然而，车库的窗户后来被螺栓锁死了，上面还布满了蜘蛛网。很明显，根本没有人从那里进来，窗纱是从里面割破的。
Shortly before his parents were attacked, Chris Porco attempted to sell a laptop he stole from a friend. Furthermore, just prior to the attack on Peter and Joan, the veterinary clinic Chris previously worked for reported some electronic devices and a cell phone had been stolen. The intruder had staged the scene at the veterinary clinic to look like a break-in by shattering a window. They had disarmed the alarm and reactivated it after stealing the goods. The clinic's cell phone was later found in the Porco family safe.
就在父母遭到袭击前不久，克里斯·波科试图出售一台从朋友那里偷来的笔记本电脑。此外，就在彼得和琼遭到袭击前不久，克里斯以前工作过的兽医诊所报告说，一些电子设备和一部手机被盗了。入侵者砸碎了一扇窗户，将兽医诊所的现场伪造得像是一起入室盗窃案。他们解除了警报，并在偷走物品后重新启动了警报。该诊所的手机后来在波科家的保险箱里被发现。
This was the beginning of an elaborate web of lies surrounding Chris Porco. His family were never wealthy like he boasted to friends and he didn't have over $2 million in an offshore bank account. According to the CBS 48 Hours documentary Memory of Murder, every time Chris's friends asked to see the mansion he claimed to have purchased in North Carolina, he came up with an excuse as to why he couldn't take them. When he took them on tours to view his lavish childhood homestead, they suspected he was pointing out a random house he'd never lived in.
这是一场围绕克里斯·波科的精心编织的谎言网的开始。他的家人根本不像他对朋友吹嘘的那样富有，他在海外银行账户里也没有超过200万美元。根据哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）《48小时》纪录片《谋杀记忆》，每当克里斯的朋友要求参观他声称在北卡罗来纳州买下的豪宅时，他总能找借口解释为什么不能带他们去。当他带他们参观他奢华的童年故居时，他们怀疑他只是随便指了一栋他从未住过的房子。
They found Chris's stories exaggerated and hard to believe, but he did always seem to have cash on him and was, quote, such a lovely guy that they gave him the benefit of the doubt. These lies seemed relatively harmless and only served as a means for Chris to grandstand his otherwise ordinary life. However, there was one lie that hinted at a deeper problem Chris had with confronting the reality of his life decisions. According to his friends, rather than having a bout of glandular fever that set back his
他们发现克里斯的故事被夸大了，很难让人相信，但他身上似乎总是带着现金，而且“是个非常讨人喜欢的人”，所以他们还是选择相信他。这些谎言似乎相对无害，只是克里斯用来在原本平凡的生活中大肆吹嘘的手段。然而，有一个谎言暗示了克里斯在面对自己生活决策的现实时存在的更深层次的问题。据他的朋友说，克里斯并没有得过什么腺热导致学业耽误，而是经常因为聚会和过度饮酒而逃课。由于表现不佳而被罗切斯特大学劝退后，克里斯注册了社区学院，但再次缺课。由于不想让父母发现，他向父母撒谎，说自己已经通过了考试，并已被罗切斯特大学重新录取。事实上，克里斯伪造了一份成绩单，给了自己三个A和一个B，以此重新进入大学。当他回去时，克里斯告诉父母，他根本没有挂过科，
studies, Chris often skipped classes due to partying and excessive drinking. After being asked to leave the University of Rochester due to poor performance, Chris enrolled in community college, but once again failed to attend. Not wanting his parents to find out, he lied to them, telling them he passed and had been accepted back into the University of Rochester. In reality, Chris forged a fake transcript, giving himself three A's and a B to get back into university. When he returned, Chris told his parents that he'd never failed any subjects in the first
而是因为一位教授弄丢了他参加过的一门考试才被错怪劝退的。克里斯告诉彼得和琼，为了弥补这个错误，学校同意支付整整一个学期的学费。这完全是个谎言。2004年10月7日，即袭击发生前六周，克里斯向父亲寻求帮助，希望获得2000美元的贷款来支付一些学校费用。彼得同意了，并将个人信息发给克里斯，以便他能成为共同签署人。相反，克里斯利用这些信息获得了31000美元的贷款，并伪造了父亲的签名
place, but had mistakenly been asked to leave after a professor lost an exam he had taken. Chris told Peter and Joan that to make up for the mistake, the University offered to pay the tuition fees for a full semester. This was a complete lie. On October 7, 2004, six weeks before the attack, Chris asked his father for help to secure a $2,000 loan to pay for some school expenses. Peter agreed and sent personal information to Chris so he could become a co-signatory. Instead, Chris used this information to secure a $31,000 loan and forged his father's signature
申请表上的签名。当一封通知他贷款已获批准的信件寄到他家时，彼得发现了这一点。彼得给银行打电话取消了贷款。然后他给罗切斯特大学财务部门打电话，对方保证学校并没有为克里斯支付这学期的学费。因此，彼得自己支付了学费。几周后，克里斯开着一辆崭新的黄色吉普牧马人来看望父母。
on the application. Peter discovered this when a letter arrived at his house informing him that the loan had been approved. Peter rang the bank and cancelled the loan. He then rang the University of Rochester Finance Department, who assured Peter that the University was not paying for Chris's semester of tuition. As a result, Peter paid for the tuition himself. A few weeks later, Chris showed up to visit his parents in a brand new yellow Jeep Wrangler.
他告诉他们，这是别人用一些旧电脑送给他的礼物。事实上，克里斯伪造了父亲的签名，获得了16450美元的贷款来购买这辆吉普车。出于善意，彼得同意继续作为该笔贷款的共同签署人，允许克里斯保留这辆车。然而，克里斯很快就拖欠了贷款还款。袭击发生前十天，彼得给克里斯发了一封电子邮件，解释说他需要支付逾期还款，以免他们的信用评级受到不利影响。邮件结束了。
He told them it had been gifted to him in exchange for some used computers. In reality, Chris had forged his father's signature to obtain a loan for the amount of $16,450 to purchase the Jeep. In good faith, Peter agreed to remain co-signatory on the loan, allowing Chris to keep the car. However, Chris soon fell behind in the loan repayments. Ten days before the attack, Peter emailed Chris explaining that he needed to pay for the outstanding repayments to avoid their credit ratings being adversely affected. The email ended.
妈妈一直在给你发邮件，但你没有回复。你有很多事情要解释。是时候停止废话，马上给我打电话了。不久之后，彼得发了另一封电子邮件，解释说他很不情愿地替克里斯偿还了贷款。他写道：“我想让你知道，如果你再次滥用我的信用，我将被迫在戴vid之后以伪造罪起诉，以免除责任。”
Mum's been trying to email you but you have not answered. You have a lot of explaining to do. It's time to stop the bullshit and call me right away. Shortly after, Peter sent another email explaining that he'd reluctantly paid the loan repayments for Chris. He wrote, I want you to know that if you abuse my credit again, I will be forced to file forgery after David's in order to disclaim liability.
袭击发生前一周，克里斯仍然没有联系他的父母。琼给他发了一封邮件，上面写着：“爸爸和我很生你的气，因为你不跟我们联系。我们不知道你是否健康，精神是否稳定。爸爸快要精神崩溃了。你明白自己没有责任心吗？看在上帝的份上，打个电话吧。”侦探们的理论是，这些持续的财务问题是导致
One week before the attack, Chris still hadn't contacted his parents. Joan sent him an email that read, Dad and I are very upset about your not communicating with us. We don't know if you are well or mentally stable. Dad is about to have a nervous breakdown. Do you understand that you are not behaving responsibly? For God's sakes, call. Detectives worked on the theory that these ongoing financial issues were what motivated
克里斯对父母发动了残酷的袭击。案发当天早上，他的银行账户透支了117美元，但就在几周前，他曾拜访过一位理财顾问，称自己即将从一位亲戚那里获得数百万美元。他要求制定一个投资组合。侦探们认为，克里斯不想放弃他为自己虚构的奢华生活方式，为了维持这种生活，他会不择手段，甚至杀死父母以获取人寿保险。
Chris to launch the brutal attack on his parents. On the morning of the crime, his bank accounts were overdrawn by $117, but just weeks prior, he had visited a financial advisor and said he was about to receive millions of dollars from a relative. He requested that a portfolio be drawn up. Detectives believed Chris didn't want to give up the lavish lifestyle he had falsely created for himself and would go to great lengths to maintain it, killing his parents for their life insurance policies.
2005年11月4日，在彼得和琼·波科遇袭近一年后，克里斯·波科因这起罪行被正式逮捕。大陪审团以二级谋杀父亲和企图谋杀母亲的罪名起诉了他。当他戴着手铐被带出法庭并被拘留以等待两周后举行的保释听证会时，他显得镇定自若。即将到来的审判给控方带来了一个不寻常的难题。琼·波科知道有如山的证据将克里斯牵连其中。
On November 4, 2005, almost a year after Peter and Joan Porco were attacked, Chris Porco was formally arrested for the crime. A grand jury indicted him for the second degree murder of his father and attempted murder of his mother. He appeared calm and collected as he was led from the courtroom in handcuffs and taken into custody to await a bail hearing set for two weeks time. The upcoming trial presented an unusual problem for the prosecution. Joan Porco was aware of the mountain of evidence that implicated Chris.
尽管如此，她依然坚定不移地坚信他是无辜的。她认为财务动机荒谬绝伦，根本不愿协助控方。地区检察官大卫·索亚雷斯（David Soares）对记者说：“归根结底，这里的问题在于，为了给琼·波科讨回公道，我们必须判定她的儿子有罪。”这与琼是否给予祝福无关。琼全力支持儿子在审判前获得保释出狱。
Regardless, she was unwaveringly convinced of his innocence. She thought a financial motive was ludicrous and was unwilling to help the prosecution at all. District Attorney David Soares told reporters, Ultimately, the issue here is in order to get justice for Joan Porco. We have to find her son guilty. This was regardless of whether it came with Joan's blessing. Joan fully supported her son to be released on bail pending trial.
她在写给法官的一封信中写道：“尽管我仍在从袭击中恢复的过程中，但我有很多机会和克里斯在一起。在所有这些时间里，他一直是彼得和我抚养的那个充满爱心的人，并且继续以他在袭击前表现出的同样尊重对待我。我在他身边毫无畏惧。”朋友们设法筹集了25,000美元的现金来满足克里斯的保释要求。他走出了法院，对询问他近况的记者报以微笑。
In a letter to the judge, she wrote, Even though I am still in the process of recovering from the attack, I have had many occasions to be with Chris. During all of those times, he has been the same loving person that Peter and I raised and continues to treat me with the same respect that he showed before the attack. I have no fear being in his presence. And friends managed to collect $250,000 cash to meet Chris's bail requirements. He walked from the courthouse, fushing a smile at reporters who asked how he was doing.
他回答说：“其实我感觉挺好的，我只想让你们知道，我是无辜的。”接下来的周末，克里斯和母亲在一家酒店度过，母亲见到他非常高兴。在等待审判期间，他把时间花在奥尔巴尼市中心的俱乐部里，由于当地对该案的大量报道，他在那里成了某种名人。女孩们要求与他合影，急于向朋友们展示她们遇到了被指控谋杀的男子。2006年6月27日，克里斯·波科在母亲的陪同下来到奥兰治县法院。
He replied, I feel pretty good actually, and I just want you to know, I'm innocent. Chris spent the following weekend at a hotel with his mother who was delighted to see him. While awaiting trial, he spent his time going to clubs in downtown Albany, where he had become somewhat of a celebrity due to the extensive local reporting on the case. Girls asked to have their photo taken with him, eager to show friends they had met the man accused of murder. On June 27, 2006, Chris Porco arrived at the Orange County Courthouse accompanied by his mother.
由于他的律师成功辩称，由于媒体对该案的广泛关注，他在家乡无法得到公正的审判，因此审判地点已从奥尔巴尼转移。当他们手挽手走进法院时，克里斯为琼撑着伞。在高大健壮的儿子衬托下，琼显得消瘦而脆弱。她戴着一副大大的深色墨镜，遮住了她在袭击中受到的假眼和脸上的部分疤痕。尽管琼努力保持低调，但她仍然是她儿子审判中的核心人物。辩方辩称，她不可能认出克里斯是袭击者，因为
The venue had been changed from Albany after his attorneys successfully argued he wouldn't get a fair trial in his home county due to the extensive media interest in the case. Chris held an umbrella out for Joan as they walked into the courthouse arm in arm. Joan looked thin and frail next to her tall and strapping son. She wore large, dark sunglasses that hid the glass eye and some of the scarring to her face she had received from the attack. Despite her efforts to remain relatively inconspicuous, Joan was a major focus in her son's trial. The defense argued that she couldn't have identified Chris as her attacker as it was
袭击发生时卧室里太黑了。他们还辩称，在布迪什侦探在卧室盘问琼之前，应该先评估她的认知能力，以确保她明白被问的问题。尽管琼否认暗示她的儿子，但在布迪什盘问她时，卧室里有多个紧急医疗救护人员在场。他们都证实了他的叙事版本。琼承认克里斯是她的袭击者。辩方还强调了琼的故事，即她看到一个陌生人在车道上
too dark in the bedroom when the assault took place. They also argued that Joan's cognitive abilities should have been assessed before Detective Boudish questioned her in the bedroom to make sure she understood what was being asked. Even though Joan denied implicating her son, multiple paramedics were present in the bedroom when Boudish questioned her. They all verified his version of events. Joan had agreed Chris was her assailant. The defense also highlighted Joan's story of having seen a stranger in her driveway two
袭击发生前几周。他们批评警方当时没有调查这起事件，并暗示布迪什侦探的工作尤为草率。控方称辩方关于警方工作粗制滥造的说法荒谬绝伦，并透露案发后波科家附近的200多名邻居接受了讯问。但警方并非完全没有过错。审判法官认定，对克里斯在袭击当天进行的讯问
weeks before the attack. They were critical of the police for not investigating this incident at the time, suggesting Detective Boudish in particular was sloppy in his work. The prosecution called the defense's claim of shoddy police work preposterous, revealing that over 200 neighbors in the vicinity of the Porco House were interviewed after the crime. But the police were not entirely without fault. The trial judge established that the interview conducted with Chris on the day of the attack
由于在宣读米兰达警告时出现错误，该口供被视为无效。当彼得和琼的长子乔纳森·波科（Jonathan Porco）走上证人席时，法庭上一片寂静，他避免与弟弟对视。虽然他最初支持克里斯，但琼承认他和克里斯的关系很奇怪。他没有再详细说明。约翰还透露，他们两人都知道，在父母去世的情况下，他们将继承超过100万美元的人寿保险和福利。当严重受伤的琼的照片闪现在法庭屏幕上时，克里斯
was inadmissible, due to the errors made in not reading Chris his Miranda rights. Silence filled the courtroom as Peter and Joan's eldest son Jonathan Porco took the stand, avoiding eye contact with his brother. While he initially stood by Chris, Joan admitted that he and Chris had a strange relationship. He didn't elaborate any further. John also revealed that they were both aware they stood to inherit over $1 million in life insurance and benefits in the event of their parents' death. When photos of the critically injured Joan were flashed on a courtroom screen, Chris
波科摘下眼镜擦去眼泪。照片过于血腥，法官下令用黑白而不是彩色播放。休息期间，琼经常过去拥抱克里斯，两人被看到一起微笑。在出示了85名证人和450件证据后，辩护团队辩称，由于事件的时间线是间接的且缺乏法医证据，控方并未证明其案件成立。他们指出，屋里没有找到血迹或DNA来将克里斯与罪行联系起来。
Porco removed his glasses to wipe away tears. The photos were so graphic that the judge ordered them to be shown in black and white rather than color. During breaks Joan often went over to embrace Chris and the two were seen smiling together. After 85 witnesses and 450 pieces of evidence were presented, the defense team contended that the prosecution hadn't proved its case due to a circumstantial timeline of events and a lack of forensic evidence. They cited that no blood or DNA was found in the house to link Chris to the crimes.
唯一能证明克里斯在屋里的证据——他在地下室门上的指纹，可以很容易地用他在案发前多次造访该住所来解释。8月10日，陪审团离开法庭以决定克里斯·波科的命运。在他们商议期间，记者问克里斯，如果有机会，他会对陪审团成员说些什么。克里斯敦促他们不要妄下结论，并说道：“一旦你看清了全貌，我认为事情就很清楚了，根本说不通。”
The one thing placing Chris in the house, his fingerprint on the basement door, could be easily explained by his multiple visits to the home prior to the crime. On August 10, the jury left the courtroom to decide Chris Porco's fate. While they were deliberating, reporters asked Chris what he would tell the jury members if he had the chance. Chris urged them not to jump to conclusions, saying, Once you look at the whole picture, I think it's pretty clear that things just don't add up.
人们原本预计这会是一个漫长而痛苦的过程，但在六个小时后，陪审团带着裁决回到法庭，震惊了所有人。由于预计审判商议需要很长时间，琼·波科已经退到附近酒店的房间里休息，宣判时并未在场。因二级谋杀父亲彼得和企图谋杀母亲琼的罪名，克里斯·波科被判有罪。宣读裁决时他保持着镇定，但他的面部表情却出卖了他冷漠的态度，他的脸变得通红。
Joan was expected to be a long and drawn out process, but six hours in, the jury shocked everyone by returning to the courtroom with a verdict. Anticipating a lengthy deliberation, Joan Porco had retired to rest in her nearby hotel room and wasn't present when the verdict was announced. For the second degree murder of his father Peter and the attempted murder of his mother Joan, Chris Porco was found guilty. He remained calm as the verdict was read, but his nonchalant attitude was betrayed by his face, which turned bright red.
尽管赢得了定罪，但首席助理地区检察官表示，没有什么值得庆祝的，因为“整件事都是一场悲剧”。彼得的妹妹帕蒂表达了一种如释重负的感觉，她告诉媒体，他们的下一个挑战将是收拾残局，尝试以家庭身份重新开始。两个月后，克里斯出现在奥尔巴尼县法院接受判决。虽然琼要求对她的儿子宽大处理，但帕蒂宣读了一份受害者影响陈述，其中说道：“这个行为是一个人类对另一个人所能做出的最冷酷、最野蛮的行为。”
Despite winning a conviction, the chief assistant district attorney said there was no cause for celebration as, quote, the whole thing is a tragedy. Peter's sister Patty expressed the sense of relief, telling the media that their next challenge would be to pick up the pieces and try to rebuild as a family. Two months later, Chris appeared at the Albany County Courthouse for sentencing. While Joan asked for leniency towards her son, Patty read a victim impact statement that said, This act was the coldest, most barbaric act any human being can commit against another.
我太生气了，因为我和弟弟的未来被剥夺了，尤其是他在为他人奉献了多年生命之后，竟然没能实现自己的梦想和潜力。法庭上还宣读了彼得母亲的一封信。信中说：“我并不完全理解我的孙子身上发生了什么，我希望并祈祷他能被治愈。但除非这种情况发生，否则决不能让他再次杀人。”克里斯指责警方将他与父亲之间的小纠纷断章取义，并
I am so angry that my future with my brother has been taken away, and especially that after giving years of his life for others, he did not get to live out his own dreams and potential. A letter from Peter's mother was also read out to the courtroom. In it, she said, I do not fully understand what happened to my grandson, and I hope and I pray that he can be cured. But unless that happens, he must not be allowed to kill again. Chris blamed the police for taking a minor dispute with his father out of context and
利用它来诬陷他谋杀。他说：“在我爸爸被带走之前，我从来没能跟他说声再见。他在去世前对我感到失望的想法将永远萦绕在我心头。”法官转向克里斯并宣判道：“毫无疑问，你的母亲对2004年11月凌晨发生的事件没有任何记忆。她对体制感到不满，这是非常可以理解的。
using it to incriminate him in his murder. He said, I was never able to say goodbye to my dad before he was taken from us. The idea that he was disappointed in me before he died will always haunt me. The judge turned to Chris to deliver his sentence, It is without a doubt your mother has no memory of the events which occurred in the early morning hours of November 2004. It's very understandable that she is upset with the system.
在我看来，她觉得警察做得不够，这是非常可以理解的。那是因为，对于一个生下、抚养并照顾孩子的父母来说，要相信她十月怀胎养大的孩子会有能力做出这些暴力凶残的行径，这将是世界上最困难的事情。”今天在对你进行宣判时，我必须向你解释并让你明白，之所以对你施加这样的刑罚，是因为我非常担心发生的事情可能会再次发生。尽管琼恳求在她的有生之年释放克里斯，但他还是被判处了最高刑期
It is very understandable to me that she feels the police didn't do enough. That's because it would be the most difficult thing in the world for a parent to believe that their child, who she gave birth to and raised and took care of, would be capable of being the perpetrator of these violent heinous acts. In sentencing you today, I've got to explain to you and make you understand that the sentence that's being imposed upon you is because I fear very much that what happened is something that could happen again. Despite Jones' plea that Chris be freed within her lifetime, he was given the maximum sentence
判处50年至无期徒刑。克里斯随后两次对他的定罪提出上诉，但均以有压倒性证据支持定罪为由被驳回。随后，他向美国最高法院提起上诉，但在2012年4月，法院宣布将不会审理他的案件，从而为克里斯的上诉程序画上了句号。2013年，克里斯试图起诉终身娱乐网络（Lifetime Entertainment Network），因为他们制作了一部关于此案的电视电影，名为《罗密欧杀手：克里斯·波科的故事》（Romeo Killer, the Chris Porco Story）。克里斯试图阻止该电影的宣传和播出，声称该
of 50 years to life imprisonment. Chris went on to appeal his conviction twice, but was rejected both times on grounds of there being overwhelming evidence to support his conviction. He then appealed to the US Supreme Court, but in April 2012, it was announced the court wouldn't be hearing his case, putting an end to Chris' appeals process. In 2013, Chris attempted to sue the Lifetime Entertainment Network after they made a TV movie about the case titled Romeo Killer, the Chris Porco story. Chris tried to put a halt to the advertising and airing of the movie, claiming that the
电影不当使用了他的姓名、肖像和个性。虽然诉讼曾短暂取得成功，但最终还是被驳回了，这部电影的宣传语是：“克里斯·波科不想让你看的电影”。它于2013年3月播出，反响平平。克里斯·波科至今仍坚称自己无罪，对对待父母的方式毫无悔意。他在狱中告诉《48小时》栏目：“这是一场悲剧，不仅对我是如此，对我的家人来说也是如此。
film wrongfully used his name, likeness, and personality. While temporarily successful, the lawsuit was eventually tossed, and the film was marketed as, the movie Chris Porco doesn't want you to see. It aired in March 2013, to lukewarm reviews. Chris Porco still professes his innocence and has shown no remorse for the way he treated his parents. From his prison cell, he told 48 Hours, It's a tragedy, not really just for me, but, you know, for my family.
我母亲现在必须一个人生活，坐在里面，这让我很难接受。”如果表现良好，克里斯·波科将在2052年12月获得假释资格。在整个谋杀审判期间，家人、朋友和同事纷纷表达了对彼得·波科的爱。当琼出庭作证时，她向法庭讲述了她的丈夫作为一名律师工作有多么努力。当孩子还小的时候，他放弃了备受瞩目的职业生涯，找了一份法律文员的工作，这样他就可以花更多的时间陪伴家人。
My mother's now gonna have to live alone, and that's very hard for me to stomach sitting in here. With good behaviour, Chris Porco will become eligible for parole in December 2052. Throughout the murder trial, messages of love for Peter Porco were shared by family, friends, and colleagues. When Joan testified, she told the court how hard her husband had worked as an attorney. He'd given up his high-profile career when his children were young, taking a job as a law clerk so he could spend more time with his family.
虽然收入减少了，但琼对这种改变感到很高兴，因为它给波科家族带来了一种亲密感。琼和彼得在袭击发生前五个月刚刚庆祝了结婚30周年，琼当时说她的家庭比以往任何时候都要亲密。乔纳森·波科也呼应了这一说法，他说道：“爸爸是一个努力工作、非常好的人。他热爱法律。我认为他是一个优秀的父亲。”
Although it came with a pay cut, Joan was pleased with the change as it brought a sense of closeness to the Porco household. Joan and Peter had celebrated their 30-year wedding anniversary just five months before the attack, during which Joan said her family had been as close as ever. It was a statement echoed by Jonathan Porco, who said, Dad was a hard-working, great guy. He loved the law. I think he was an excellent father.
在最初检查波科家犯罪现场时，一名调查员偶然发现了一张彼得签署的现金支票，用于支付克里斯累积的逾期停车费。其中一个角落的血迹表明，即使在遭到克里斯的恶毒袭击后，彼得仍然试图帮助他的儿子摆脱麻烦。尽管一次又一次地被欺骗，并面临财务崩溃的威胁，彼得发给克里斯的最后一封电子邮件仍然证明了他究竟是一个什么样的父亲。信中写道：“你现在显然已经失控了。
In the crime scene at the Porco's home was first examined, an investigator came across a cashier's check Peter had signed for overdue parking fees accumulated by Chris. A smear of blood in one of the corners indicated that even after being viciously assaulted by Chris, Peter was still trying to help his son get out of trouble. Despite having been lied to time and time again and threatened with financial ruin, one of the last emails Peter sent to Chris was a testament to the type of father he truly was. It read, Things are obviously spinning out of control with you.
我想你应该回家，这样我们可以谈谈。我们或许对你感到失望，但你妈妈和我依然爱着你，并且关心你的未来。”这个剧集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I think you should come home so we can talk. We may be disappointed in you, but your mother and I still love you, and care about your future. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想你应该回家，这样我们才能谈谈。我们可能对你感到失望，但我和你妈妈依然爱你，关心你的未来。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。